bandits secret is certainly one of the
most versatile known abilities in
existence I mean it's just absolutely
impossible to plan against primarily
because krolow could pull literally
anything out of that book like say for
example a YouTube subscribe button which
forcibly subscribes his opponent to this
channel in order to have regular Hunter
hunter content uploaded straight into
their YouTube feed and just you know
good luck improvising against that I
don't consider Judas to be a traitor
they say Judas salt Jesus over 430
silver coins
how much would this traitor sell us out
for think about it what would he gain by
selling us to the Mafia money fame
status would that really gratify any one
of us hello and welcome to Hunter hunter
101 the series that breaks down everyone
and everything in the Hunter hunter
world and today we're going to be
examining one of the more prolific
figures in this series being the leader
of the infamous phantom troupe Kroll Oh
Lucifer Crowley Lucifer is a relatively
young man with a very bold sense of
fashion we should say referring to Don a
dark purple fur coat where possible oh
and an intricately detailed cross shaped
tattoo smack bang on his forehead which
you know forehead tattoos they are
always a UH a wonderful sign of sanity
but in all seriousness krohler where's
his aesthetic exceptionally well and
complements it with a consistently calm
and collected demeanor which is highly
necessary in order for him to command a
large group of exceptionally volatile
personas Rolo is also by far one of the
most intelligent characters who has ever
been introduced into haunt hunter
capable of rapidly calculating strategy
on a grandmaster scale in regards to
every facet of life necessary including
battle and furthermore krolow is one of
the rare beings in hunter hunter to show
no fear of death whatsoever which was
noted by melody when she discovered the
crawlers heartbeat sounded as if it was
completely at ease
living with the idea of death and the
combination of all of the above features
has greatly contributed to crawler being
considered one of the most dangerous
beings in the series something else I'd
also like to point out at this stage
because people always try to call me up
on this his name is Chronos Lou silver
with an L which I swear I do pronounce
but the old gets lost in my accent oh
just in the way I say things so if I
ever do say Kroll elusive fur I promise
I am recognising yell it just it gets
lost in any case this mysterious man
like much of a fandom troupe originated
from météo City a junkyard civilization
where all of the world's trash is
disposed of even people as a result
crawlers existence does not appear on
any official global records which would
go on to be a huge asset to his future
activities as at some stage during his
youth Provo would
a selection of meteo city's inhabitants
and proposed forming the phantom troupe
and in this regard chrono had a very
clear vision of the existence of this
cohort boldly claiming that while he
would form the head of the spider there
would be times where the legs would be
far more important than the head and
that the utmost priority was ensuring
the survival of the spider as a whole
and this quite wonderfully expresses the
fact that while ambitious CRO lo is in
no way a selfish individual and would
very willingly sacrifice himself in
order to ensure the safety of his fellow
troop members crawlers feelings of
concern for his fellow human beings
really do not extend much beyond this
group though as he swiftly set them to
work becoming a fearsome global force
focused on acquiring phenomenal amounts
of money through any means necessary
which can range from simple thievery all
the way to an orchestrated genocide and
in regards to that second example there
this would be implemented when the
troupe conducted the massacre of the
Kota clan for the purpose of selling the
Scarlet eyes to body-part collectors on
the black market
and given that in the series one pair of
these eyes has been sold for close to
three billion Jenny
well that essentially gives you an idea
that nothing is off limits for krola
so long as the price is right but that
said this particular incident would come
to cause quite a problem for crawler as
one member of the Kota clan was not
present for the massacre being one of
our four protagonists Cora pica who went
on to dedicate his life to taking
revenge against the troupe as well as
recover the lost eyes of his clan
members more on that in a bit though
because crawler was actually no stranger
to making enemies in this world and in
fact at one stage during his past he
even faced off directly against silver
zoldak who managed to kill an unknown
member of the phantom troupe and while
the exact details of this encounter are
unknown both combatants did manage to
survive which is already a stunning
endorsement of crawlers bra fighting
power but things become even more insane
when we delve into the art of nen in
terms of nen crow lo is a specialist
meaning that his particular affinity
cannot be boxed in or planned for
without prior knowledge of his specific
katsu and crawlers elected use of nen
primarily manifests itself in an ability
known as bandits secret and long story
short this allows crawler to steal the
nen abilities of others although long
story long it is only able to achieve
this by fulfilling the following
conditions firstly crawler must witness
the desirability in action which is
usually fairly easy
then he must ask a question about said
ability and actually have the user
answer him which can be a surprisingly
difficult one to achieve against an
experienced combatant who are highly
secretive about their particular Honsou
thirdly his victims palm must touch the
handprint of the cover abandoned secret
which I
say is the most difficult one and
finally all of this needs to be
completed within the time limit of one
hour or else crawler needs to start
again however if he does manage to
fulfill all of those conditions then he
gains access to then an ability and his
victim loses that power but one further
condition to invoke that ability is that
crawler must keep bandit secret open on
the page where that particular name
power is listed although crawler does
eventually evolve a way to circumvent
this but we'll get to that for now with
all of this equipped crawler was able to
fend off silver Zeltiq and earn the
fearful respect of one of the world's
greatest assassins showing crawler off
to be a truly terrifying force in this
world even at this relatively early
stage in the game however his modern-day
skills are even more terrifying as these
days he is capable of fighting
competently in a two-on-one format
against both silver Tzadik and his
father Zeno zoldak so just out you be
two of the greatest assassins in the
world who to be fair were very likely to
eventually defeat crawler albeit at the
cost of one of their lives but the more
Zeno himself did go on to suggest that
if they had fought one-on-one and
crawler had the intent to kill then
things may not have worked out so well
for the old assassin when it comes to
his primary involvement in the series ER
crawler would be showcased as the main
antagonist of the orcish city arc along
with the rest of the phantom troupe
whereby he ordered a mandatory gathering
of the troop members in the urban center
to raid an underground auction being
hosted by the ten Mafia dons now by this
point the troupe had a total of 13
members many of whom was still the
original party formed in meteor city
however one very notable addition to the
gang was he so Kimura an exceptionally
powerful being who had managed to defeat
a prior member of the troupe and take
their place
however Hisoka had only done so because
he fetishized the chance to fight
crawler one-on-one and as such he would
spend most of this arc constantly
undermining crawler in order to achieve
that desired climax growl I certainly
did have other problems though because
while everything went well at first
eventually crop occur the survivor of
the Kota clan Massacre made his presence
known and managed to swiftly kill a
troupe member by the name of hooligan
and while the loss of his comrade and
one of the founding members of the
troupe no less filled crawler with a
profound desire for revenge he elected
to do so in a classically calm and
collected manner in fact his first stop
would be to approach a girl named nyan
estrada daughter of lightness trod a
prominent underworld figure but now on
was important because she was also a
specialist nan user who possessed an
ability known as lovely ghostwriter
which allowed nyan to produce accurate
yet cryptic fortunes of various
individuals and through his charming
charming nature pro-law not only
and his own fortune told but he was able
to use bandit secret to fool neon and
acquire the lovely ghostwriter ability
for himself which he used to produce
fortunes for the rest of the Phantom
troupe leading to a startling result
signifying that five more members of the
gang would die if they encounter Korra
pika within the next two weeks in order
to avoid this crawler then planned to
return to meet your city to dodge his
fate and whether he Sokka use one of his
known abilities texture surprise to
alter his own fortune and coerce the
troupe into staying into your new city
to deal with Korra pika and look the
following events certainly do not play
out well as krolow would be captured by
crop occur and have an end coast on him
through the judgment chain ability
giving crawler the commands of not being
able to contact the rest of the troupe
nor was he able to invoke known in
general in the breaking of either of
those rules would result in his
immediate death
furthermore the troupe lost another
member in park geun Oda who chose to
sacrifice herself to inform the rest of
the members of exactly what had gone
down but with krohler artificially
ostracized from the Phantom troupe he
then focused on the part of his prophecy
that nyan had written fam indicating
that he would go east the destination
that would like to be revealed to be
greed island and after acquiring a copy
of the game crawler was even able to
recruit Hisoka to enter it for him and
just to be clear crawlers communication
with Hisoka is technically allowed on to
caracas conditions because he Sokka was
only ever pretending to be a troupe
member but alas he sent the mad magician
in to source an exorcist to remove crop
occurs curse which Hisoka did eventually
find and provide in the hopes of
eventually achieving his dream of
fighting crawler and at this point I
guess I have to throw out the mandatory
spoiler warning for non margaritas I
mean at this point all this happened two
years and years and years ago and who
knows if it will ever be animated but if
you're still concerned about being
spoiled from longer events then please
do skip to this time but for everyone
else we aren't going to continue to the
good stuff
so after successfully having crop ACCA's
curse removed crawler took up his Hocus
challenge and the two would fight in
Heaven's arena but interestingly enough
chrono had earned the status of floor
master however this was no ordinary
bound as crawler had gone to great
lengths to plan a perfect strategy to
deal with Hisoka part of which was the
development of a new original ability
known as double faced which produced a
bookmark to be used in concert with
bandit secret allowing Carollo to keep
an inability active on the page marked
but he also came equipped with five
other borrowed and or stolen abilities
the combination of which allowed him to
utterly dominate and eventually kill
Hisoka from here crawler planned to
assemble the true pond the black where
one the vessel publicly bound for the
consonant and populated by the royal
family of the car cane Empire which
naturally growler was a keen on
acquiring their vast fortune however his
purpose aboard the ship would come too
abruptly change when it was discovered
that he Sokka had invoked post-mortem
nen to bring himself back to life and
went on to kill two other phantom troupe
members being [ __ ] and korto P and at
this point growler began showing emotion
like actual emotion which is incredibly
uncharacteristic of him consisting
primarily of rage and despair and when
what was left of the troupe did finally
assemble aboard the black whale one
crawler made their primary objective to
find and kill Hisoka and currently crow
Lo is on the hunt to do exactly that
some more fun facts about krohler rather
interestingly it has been shown that
crow love is capable of accessing the
Hunter website which implies that he
himself may be a hunter although it is
highly possible that he just stole the
license of a hunter or use the license
of one of his fellow troop members as at
the very least both Hisoka and [ __ ]
were licensed hunters at the time in the
fanbase at large crow low is a wildly
popular character having secured fourth
place in the second character poll in
eighth place in the third poll both of
which were conducted by weekly shonen
jump and finally a truly useless fact in
the ever ever reliable official Hunter
hunter data book Crowley's name is spelt
as cool Roth rules the truth which
honestly just feels to me like someone
just mashed their head against a
keyboard a certain amount of times
rather than bothering to type out
Crowley's name but Spelling's like this
are unfortunately not uncommon in Hunter
hunter although this is probably by far
the most butchered name we have ever
seen but that pretty much does it for
Crower
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produce in general
then please do consider donating to the
new altar view patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video
like share or subscribe because it also
helps for this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my desk or server where a wide array of
shenanigans place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
or where you'd like to see featured in
the next Hunter hunter 101
[Music]
is it hunter hunter or hunter x hunter
if it's hunter hunter what happened to
the ex alright here's a nice question
because this is one of those things that
annoys me most in this world
which is when I hear people say hunter x
hunter the X is silent and it's not
actually in X either it's a
multiplication symbol and that very much
confused as polar for Western audiences
you try to say Hunter x Hunter or hunter
x hunter but in Japan this doesn't get
confused in any way shape or form and
people just say hunter hunter and if
anybody out there does insist on
pronouncing the time symbol then I hope
that you also pronounce the titles of
series like YuYu Hakusho as U star U
star hakusho because that's essentially
the same thing